hi chris and matt my name's hannah
i need advice about a co-worker
relationship um i work with this woman
monday to friday nine hours a day and
she tells horrible stories there's no
point to them
no arc there's no beginning middle or
end she just
starts off on a story that has no point
and i don't even know what part i'm
supposed to be reacting to wow because
nothing happens in them so i just do a
lot of
wow that's crazy and uh you know like
fake laughing
and it's getting really exhausting and i
don't know maybe i should spin move out
of this one
probably not going to work so any advice
you can give me would be great i don't
know if i should say hey these stories
suck i don't know what you want from me
or if i just keep fake laughing
let me know i love you guys so much
you have no idea oh thanks i love you
too it is
a predicament i i i here's what i would
do okay at this
i don't know if i would advise this but
this is what i would do i would start
and then
increasingly do this i would start to do
this and then increasingly do it louder
and louder until she inquired about what
the [ __ ] i was doing right i would just
start saying
oh
all right and then longer and longer
and like over her story so she knows you
yeah she knows you're not even hearing
her anymore you know and then she would
be like what are you doing
what are you doing right exactly and
then you just be like
it's all i it's all i don't know what
are you doing yeah yeah
yeah um and then take it from there but
take it from there have a conversation
about it i think um well first of all
part of me wants to be like this is part
of your job like whatever job you have
that's a part of it also you have too
many drinks out here right i'm ready
dude we have too many drinks i'm always
thirsty at the end so i came [ __ ]
ready okay
you hate [ __ ] like this right yeah dude
why
like dude no
first of all there's two you have two of
these you should only have one of them
look at what i do i keep my [ __ ] clear
because i want people to be seeing
[ __ ] who cares shut the [ __ ] up the
shot's all boring why don't you like
this
question the shot's dirty you're not in
a [ __ ] you know what i mean
a [ __ ] what's his name movie what
movie the [ __ ] guy who did the uh
look though my coffee's up traffic who
did traffic stephen soderbergh my
coffee's hot my coffee is hot
it's an awfully hot coffee
drinking like a dildo
all right
yeah my [ __ ] coffee's eye dude dude
what the [ __ ] dude
um
i should do cat drink my coffee man
okay
um
so anyway
advisor okay so um [ __ ] now i'm hot and
[ __ ] oh good dude um i could not be man
you're sucking in a dildo you know what
i'm trying um [ __ ] so
i think that it's part of your job you
don't know what your job is but that
sucks but also just be like um
i mean i don't know i i what i would do
is i would say like i mean i do it to my
i have a friend that he's kind of guilty
of this he'll
he'll be like did i tell you about this
chick and i'll be like no and he'll be
like
about the chick that i met
the at the thing and i'm like no
and and then he'll be like okay so
and then it take he'll like do this
preamble of like you didn't even start
the goddamn nobody nobody needs a
preamble you didn't even you didn't even
like i know and you didn't even like
say you didn't even say anything yet you
know it's like it's like
so so there's multiple ways of telling
bad stories it sounds like she's just
wants to talk to hear herself talk it
sounds like she's actually impressively
bad at it well yeah it's kind of wanted
to hear but yeah i do too and i that's
the other thing too here's what i would
advi advise
her
is
have fun with it dude i would love to
hear a story like that yeah you would
because
it blows my mind that people like i have
friends that do that and kristen will be
like
how do you hang out with that person
yeah you and i say because it's so fun
you have the always had you have always
had the weirdest friends i know dude i
really have now you right now you have
the least weird in your i don't know i
know i do it's true i do i i need to get
back to weird friends but i do have some
but but i just have fun with it dude
this is a gift she's giving you a gift
this lady is giving you a gift she's
being boring as [ __ ] which means you are
allowed to just take that brain time off
right she's saying what she's saying
think about whatever you want and have
fun with it do the oh thing like that
yeah
yeah just i mean
are you worried about hurting your
feelings or what i don't know why you
would be though because
she's clearly oblivious to
a lot if she's telling stories like this
do an intervention with her but at a
certain point just like do whatever the
[ __ ] you want don't fake laugh don't
don't be courteous yeah you don't have
to be rude but just be
weird see what happens like this woman
clearly is something's a little bit
wrong in her head
like who the [ __ ] tells stories like
that that's a very strange thing to do
you don't begin you have no end it's
just like you just are showing words
you know it could do this is a really
great way to have fun with it
she tells her story it's very boring
yeah
keep
keep bringing it up afterwards yeah yeah
like every day multiple times a day yeah
like i can't stop thinking about
actually like that was the way you told
me like
it's really crazy you were at the park
right and you saw that guy doing karate
like yeah you know
what do you think he's doing yeah yeah
and just keep bringing it up and having
her be like
having her be the this is great having
her be the one who was like why do you
keep asking about this guy i was like
well because it was obviously really
important to you and like you know and
then she'll stop telling you stories for
sure
but then even keep bringing it up yeah
never call her late call her one text
her email her on your work god that's
crazy about the karate guy or whatever
the [ __ ] story
you know on your work email keep a
conversation this is great i wish
subject karate
subject remember the karate guy yeah
yeah yeah
karate guy update and then in the body
anything karate memorial
[Music]
hello hello